كيف صوت البا لصالح ميسي جماري يوفنتوس
تتفاعل مع عوده بوغبا رونالدينيو يعود
لملعب اسبانيا هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعون
على العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
بعد الكشف عن اختيارات المصوتين في جائزه
الافضل هاجمت جماهير ريال مدريد لعبها
كونه وقائد منتخب النمسا بعد تصويته لصالح
ميسي وليس لزميله في الفريق كريم بنزيما
لتوضيح الامور عبر تغريده على تويتر قال
فيها بان اي لاعب في منتخب النمسا يملك
الحق في التصويت وليس قائد فريقي فقط
وكانت جماهير الفريق الملكي قد هاجمت
لعبها بعبارات عنصريه عبر صفحتي على
الانستغرام مع هاشتاق البا اوت
نبقى مع اخبار جائزه الافضل وجائزه افضل
حارس ذهبت الى الارجنتيني ايميليان
ومارتينيز الذي يملك تاريخا مع مبابي نجم
منتخب فرنسا الكاميرات التقطت وجه النجم
سان جيرمان الخالي من اي تعبير اثناء تسلم
مارتينيز للجائزه بينما انهالت التصفيقات
على حارس استون فيلا من الحضور وفي
مقدمتهم ليونيل ميسي
وبعد نحو سبعه اشهر من انضمامه الى
يوفنتوس يستعد لخوض مباراه ديربي تورينو
مع فريقه
النادي مع هذا الخبر الذي يتزامن مع تحقيق
الفريق لنتائج ايجابيه على ارض الملعب
وتعرضت عديده في الفتره الماضيه في حاله
دون مشاركته مع الفريق
رغم اعتزاله لاعب كره القدم قدم
رونالدينيو فرصه عشاقه لمشاهدته في ملعب
اسبانيا رونالدو يشارك في البطوله التي
ينظمها نجم برشلونه السابق الجيران فيكي
لكن ولسوء الحظ خسر فريقه بثلاثه اهداف
مقابل هدف لكن هذه الخساره لم تمنع الحضور
من التمتع بمهارات النجم البرازيلي في
انتظار مشاركته مجددا خلال مباريات
المقبله
[موسيقى]